so former democratic congresswoman tulsi
gabbard is getting millions of views for
a new clip in which she spreads
incorrect statements that mirror
recent actual russian propaganda i'm not
using that term as a pejorative this is
this is actual russian propaganda that
was recently spread by maria bakarova as
we spoke about earlier we talked about
this in the tucker carlson segment this
is the hypothesis about u.s funded
bioweapons labs in ukraine tulsi gabbard
putting out a video about this has 2.3
million views as of this morning let's
take a look at the clip and you'll
recognize some of the same misstatements
from tulsi that we were getting on the
putin apologia show tucker carlson does
on fox news take a look here are the
undeniable facts
there are 25 to 30 u.s funded bio labs
in ukraine
according to the us government these bio
labs are conducting research on
dangerous pathogens
ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing artillery and
shelling and
these facilities
even in the best of circumstances could
easily be compromised and release these
deadly pathogens
now like covid
these pathogens know no borders
if they are inadvertently or purposely
breached or compromised they will
quickly spread
all throughout europe the united states
and the rest of the world causing untold
suffering and death
so in order to protect the american
people the people of europe the people
around the world
these labs need to be shut down
immediately and the pathogens
that they hold need to be destroyed now
understand
these are not american american labs to
shut down
biden and harris don't run the laps
and so she is again running interference
for putin because that's effectively
what this does
by shifting the conversation into
we gotta we we have hostilities going on
and if ukrainian labs are hit damaged
destroyed it's conceivable that
pathogens could be
released now that part is true
but it's not even close to being the
story of what's going on in ukraine and
of course
the right under the surface thing about
all of this is again because when when
all you have is a hammer everything
looks like a nail
the story they really want why are they
talking about this they're talking about
this because they want to attack the us
attack the us
rather than just putin invaded ukraine
that's what we should be talking about
here um let's listen to a little bit
more
instead of trying to cover this up the
biden-harris administration needs to
work with russia ukraine nato the u.n to
immediately implement a ceasefire for
all military action the vicinity of
these labs until they're secured and
these pathogens are destroyed
in addition to all this the u.s funds
around 300 bio labs around the world
who are engaging in dangerous research
including gain of function similar to
the lab in wuhan where covid19 may have
originated from so listen um
she now is talking about
covid might might have come from the lab
and she's doing the same thing tucker
did which is the fact i mean listen guys
labs exist research is done that yes
there i told you earlier there's labs
all over the world there's all sorts of
different labs all over the world world
there's a consortium called the
cooperative threat reduction program
and what they do is they research
pathogens and when she goes from the
problem is ukraine
to the point is the bio labs around the
world
why would we shut all of them down i
mean we we need to do this research is
she's just saying the research shouldn't
be done
there are no u.s run bio labs in ukraine
the country is one of many former soviet
union countries
and non-former soviet union countries
that partner with the department of
defense as part of this cooperative
threat reduction program it's public
nothing's being covered up nothing's
been covered up the goal here is
do research that would hopefully be able
to prevent biological threats it's not
to create biological threats so why
would we shut down every lab everywhere
i just don't get how do we gain from not
studying this stuff and that seems to be
what she's calling for i i was reminded
remember when mike pillow
said he wants to sue all machines oh and
he's like what are you talking about
dude tulsi seems to be saying just shut
down labs just shut them down and so
this is typical russian propaganda for
years russia has claimed that former
soviet countries are by manufacturing
biological weapons in labs funded by the
u.s it's an old russian propaganda story
now thanks to tucker carlson thanks to
tulsi gabbard they've mixed in
there's something here related to the
invasion and it's particularly
pernicious or whatever these are not
secret labs the details of american
involvement is on u.s government
websites and this program the biological
threat reduction program dates all the
way back to the 1990s and um there are
no
listen
we if you if you want to argue there
should be no bio research done well okay
argue that absent this conflict then
explain why research shouldn't be done
to me it seems incredibly stupid to say
we're just we're not going to research
it countries are developing bio weapons
we're not even going to research bio
weapon defense what what why
that doesn't make any sense
and uh they continue to make these
unsubstantiated claims and they will
continue because they are 2.3 million
views of a video in which tulsi has no
clue what she's even talking about this
stuff get clicks gets clicked so they're
going to continue doing it we have a
situation right now where many companies
want and need to hire people quickly
but it is difficult to find the right
candidates and workable is going to help
workable accelerates every step of your
hiring process workable helps you cast
the widest net possible by posting your
jobs to over 200 of the top job boards
with just one click it helps you
evaluate and hire quickly with modern
tools like video interviews and
e-signatures you can automate some of
those repetitive tasks like scheduling
interviews whether you're hiring for
your coffee shop or your engineering
team workable is exactly what you need
to hire the right people fast
start hiring today with a risk-free
15-day trial if you hire during the
trial which many do
it will cost you nothing
just go to workable.com
podcast to start hiring the link is down
below